holy it seems like forever since
I've seen you guys been like a week
since I have you guys been well in this
past subsequent weeks something kind of
cool happened ps4 was released yeah I
got that I'm I was all excited I
opened it up and it had new electronic
smell you know what I'm talking about
when you open the box to a new
electronic device you're like ah smells
good if they had a cologne fragrance
called new electronic I would apply that
daily in any case I wanted to give you
guys my thoughts on the ps4 thus far
I've been playing it for a couple days
so I figure eight why not apply what I
have learned to you all however it is a
system launch not gonna lie when's the
last time a system launch had great
games but the Nintendo 64 was like the
last really awesome launch everything
else since then it's been here's the
system don't worry games are coming in
terms of day one games I'll actually
give the Xbox one that on Dead Rising 3
and killer instinct alone good job Xbox
one dude is Killer Instinct the game
might suck ass I don't know I haven't
played it I haven't seen reviews on it
but come on you remember combo breaker
yeah you know what I'm talking about my
ps4 I looked at the launch games it's
like not really anything I'm feeling
except injustice gods among us Ultimate
Edition it justice gods among us is
really funny the more you play it the
more you love it so I took the cheap
route got the ultimate edition of
injustice gods among us because now I
have a game we don't have to learn
however it's not about that first thing
I'm going to talk about is remote play
it was promised by Sony that you can
take a ps4 game play it on ps4 and then
take your Vita and link it to the ps4
and play your ps4 game on your PS Vita
wirelessly and you can but you can
notice a couple of issues depending on
how OCD you are about that if
you're coming straight off the ps4 and
you've been playing the game on the ps4
and you play it on the Vita you notice
it's not in 60 frames a second on the
Vita it's about 30 max but the game is
completely playable the only bummer is
the resolution on the Vita is the same
as it is on your TV on your TV oh sweet
I can read that text and I've taken it
for granted now I put it on my Vita I
don't know if there say oh wow that text
is so small you don't really think about
what goes into porting a game to the
Vita they make the text bigger so you
can read it on the smaller screen but
when you're doing remote play on your
Vita playing a ps4 game everything is
exactly as it is on your TV so the text
is really small
undeniably the biggest frustration about
remote plays you're playing the PS Vita
which just has an L and R button but the
ps4 controller has l1 r1 l2 R to the L
to r2 buttons are activated by touching
the back of the Vita which is where your
fingers lie and that's always been
difficult for me I like holding my video
with my fingers resting on the back so
it's hard to hold it without that I was
hoping you'd have a function to where
you can link into the Internet at your
friend's house and if your ps4 is linked
to the internet at your house you can
link to it 50 miles away and play one of
your ps4 games on your Vita I haven't
found that function yet I hope they come
out with it I've heard people talk about
how you can do that I haven't found it
but that could be as simple as a patch
down the road point is day one you have
remote play and I'm glad they weren't
like oh remote please come and here's
here's ps4 and launch day but don't
worry a few months from now you'll have
Remote Play right now you have remote
play and that's actually really cool
it's important on a launch day to show
what your system can do in a system
interface and connectivity with other
systems I will say this for remote play
the PS Vita to the ps4 has longer range
better connectivity and is not lying a
site like the Wii U controller so if
you're pissed off that you can't play
your Wii U in your bed with the
controller because it's line-of-sight
and your Wii U is in the other room
don't worry you might be able to still
do with your PS Vita and ps4
I like the home menu and interface of
the ps4 the PS Vita the song and the
menu is really it makes me feel like I
just want to get on with the game or
whatever I'm doing to get that menu
music out ps4 music though it's very zen
it's like meditation music if you put it
on and you just meditate you go into a
coma state so I like the ps4 menu music
good job Sony on that the controller is
really comfortable to PlayStation
controllers have really remained the
same since PlayStation 1 design that is
I mean they've all relatively looked the
same ps4 is the biggest difference feels
like it's made out of a different
material it's software analog
controllers are really nice it's just
everything in there looks and feels cool
and that big black screen in the middle
of the controller that's actually a
touch screen that really works well if
you're doing an internet browser
something that requires a mouse now you
have a mouse well like a laptop mouse
it's a touchscreen Mouse thing which it
works for laptops so I suppose it would
work for PlayStation 4 there's not a lot
to talk about right now for the ps4 it
came out this last weekend there's just
a few launch games for it but seeing
this tech you see what can
come in the future I would like a higher
framerate when doing remote play I would
like to be able to do remote play
through the internet not have to be in
the same house as the system that would
be awesome I feel like in this
technological Wonderland that we all
live in I feel like these are
possibilities so we will see what
happens ps4 is like any other
playstation system or any other
PlayStation launch which is like the
female orgasm it takes a while to get
going but once it gains momentum it is
awesome when is Metal Gear Solid 5 is
going to come out for ps4 and it'll all
make sense
so the ps4 have you played it what do
you think about it and are you waiting
for the Xbox one
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more